hello do you work here guilty listen Joe
we went along with you in season one of
you even though you did some pretty
terrible things and then we went along
with you in season two because well wait
why do we keep watching even though we
know you're just about the creepiest guy
out there what does that say about us
yes
[Applause]
you has become one of the most popular
shows on Netflix and we can't seem to
keep our eyes off of its leading man Joe
will admit it we're addicted but the
true story behind this thrilling series
might just have us questioning
everything we thought we knew about you
before we get into all of the juicy
details we've got to warn you that there
are some light spoilers ahead for the
second season of you we won't give away
too much we promise but if you haven't
seen it and want to go in knowing
nothing at all then maybe put this video
on pause and come back when you've
checked out all of the drama for
yourself with that out of the way let's
get into it just in case you didn't
obsessively binge all of season 2 and
then go back and re-watch season 1 again
like some people we know us here's a
quick refresher on you the show follows
Joe a seemingly mild-mannered well-read
guy who just wants to recommend the
perfect book to his customers have you
been naughty or nice that is until he
becomes obsessed with a woman who
catches his eye and goes to terrifyingly
extreme lengths to become the perfect
boyfriend even if it means taking out
her friends and eventually locking her
in a cage among other things season 1
ended with Joe doing the unthinkable and
attacking back the woman who we and he
thought was the love of his life except
that's Joe's number one problem he
thinks every woman he becomes obsessed
with is the love of his life right in
season 2 we find him in Los Angeles
hating the entire city before finding
work at another bookstore all while
trying to outrun his demons from the
past of course Joe is still doing what
Joe now going by will by the way does
best
fixating on another girl love while it
all seems random at first and like Joe
really is trying to rid himself of these
old habits we quickly learned that
things are a whole lot messier than they
seem
but while the story of you might seem
too crazy to be real some out there are
wondering if it's all based off of true
events in this day and age where
everyone puts everything out there on
social media for the world to see it's
actually not that hard to imagine that
it could be who of us can say that they
haven't cyber stalked our crush once or
twice we know we have and it's almost
too easy but luckily there's a pretty
big difference between a little light
googling and going so far as to
infiltrate every corner of someone's
life and then assassinate everyone
around them in an effort to control and
manipulate their feelings for you right
in some very welcome good news the story
of you isn't actually based off of any
specific real-life person to speak oh
it's actually based off of a very
popular novel of the same name written
by Carolyn kept Ness which was a huge
hit and pretty much outlines the entire
first season of the show in order to
create the character of Joe kept Ness
tried to imagine the perfect guy the
hero that anyone would jump to Center a
romantic comedy around and then added a
vicious twist the good news about the
reality of this major cyber creep pretty
much ends their cyber stalking is
actually a huge problem and as we live
more and more of our lives online it has
become easier than it has ever been to
track someone using their social media
recently in Japan a man was arrested
after he tracked down a young woman by
analysing the reflections in her eyes
from her selfies in order to find out
what train stations she frequented and
trust us when we say that is not the
first time something like this has
happened there are hundreds of cases
just as creepy as that one popping up
all over the place that make Joe look
less like a work of fiction and more
like he was plucked straight from a news
headline
I'm over there and Joe and not only is
social media stalking a dangerous game
for those who are on the receiving end
of the attention it actually encourages
us all to act a little more like Joe
everyday like we mentioned before we've
all been there right we've developed a
crush on someone and then started
following them on Instagram and then we
see some recurring people who pop up in
all of their photos and we're naturally
curious as to who they are we wonder if
they could be that person's girlfriend
or boyfriend so we decide to investigate
casually of course so we keep clicking
and scrolling and the next thing we know
it's 2:00 in the morning and we're 35
people deep into someone's life being
extra careful not to accidentally like
their sister's best friends brothers
cousins girlfriends dogs picture from 67
weeks ago the kind of general
information that we get on social media
only makes us want to know more to want
all of the details to put the puzzle
together but the puzzle piece is
presented on Instagram or snapchat are
rarely enough to actually get to the
truth so all we end up doing is drawing
our own conclusions by making up stories
that don't make all that much sense and
maybe that's one of the reasons that we
have a hard time seeing Joe as just a
villain we'd never take it as far as he
does and his violent streak definitely
sets him apart but we can't escape how
easy it is to fall down those social
media rabbit holes and just get a little
carried away which is exactly what the
creators of this show want us to feel
believe it or not the entire show was
created to show us things either about
ourselves or about the people who we
fall for and make us ask those weird
questions about why when reading the
original book showrunner Sarah Campbell
found herself rooting for Joe and Bek to
stay together all the way to the end
even after Joe had shown his true colors
again and again and again that's why
when she started making you she tried to
make it as much like a classic rom-com
as possible because when you think about
it most of the heroes in our favorite
romantic comedies are kind of giant
creeps they are overly persistent don't
take no for an answer
have a habit of chasing people a whole
lot more than anyone should in real life
Gamble has even said that if you replace
the heartwarming music in any rom-com
with a David Fincher style scary
soundtrack it would change the entire
meaning of the movie
which is basically what she did with you
rooting for the bad guy is something
that goes back centuries and the list of
questionable characters who we want to
get the girl in the end goes on and on
from Edward in Twilight who while dreamy
is super possessive and controlling all
the way back to Heathcliff and
weathering Heights who all around suck
and literally has a woman trapped in an
attic but who we spoon for and then the
less there's no real scientific reason
for why we see these types of characters
is attractive but there are definitely
some theories about it
there really is something to the idea of
someone who loves you so much that
they'll do anything to be with you
and we mean anything but look while that
might be a nice idea in theory in
practice it's a whole other story what
we actually want is someone who has
their own life as well as an interest in
ours and someone who won't follow our
best friend out jogging and hit her over
the head with a rock because he thinks
she's turning us against him that is all
bad news and nothing that any of us
should ever aspire to but that's why we
have entertainment right as a way to
live out those ill-advised fantasies
without actually having to live through
them penn badgley himself has come out
to question our collective thirst for
Joe the actor has taken to Twitter to
respond to fans who tweeted him about
how attractive they find his character
asking them to think more closely about
why exactly that might be he says that
because so many of our movies and TV
throughout history have portrayed
characters like Joe as heroes or objects
of affections that we have actually
become conditioned to do backflips in
order to justify their actions he knows
that the way he plays the character and
the way he looks share a big part of the
responsibility for why we love Joe and
has been open about how a different
actor or actress might get an entirely
different reception Penn says that he
likes to see the show as a bit of a
social experiment about how far they can
push the character before fans
eventually turn on him the thing is the
more complicated Joe gets the more
compelling the show is if he were just a
one-dimensional bad boy or a boring
run-of-the-mill good
we'd probably all have lost interest by
now but because he is a very confused
and confusing young man who has yes done
some horrible things we relate to the
fact that he isn't perfect because none
of us are sure our imperfections don't
usually lead to the same psychopathic
tendencies that Joe's do and we're
grateful for that but watching him
struggle against his demons and actually
try to be a good guy makes for some
seriously entertaining TV but in any
case we're about to go change all of our
social media to private we seriously
suggest you do the same well we don't
think we should be too freaked out to
post on social media ever again and
return to the dark ages before computers
it is good to be reminded just how
public public really is and to think
about who you want to show all of your
activity to but next time you get a
crush on some cutie in a bookstore
remember a little light social media
stocking never hurt anybody just as long
as it doesn't end up with someone locked
up forever in a soundproof plexiglass
box what did you think of this video
are you a Joe Stan or do you find the
whole thing a little too creepy are you
gonna think twice before posting on
social media or do you feel fine to keep
on sharing let us know in the comments
and we hope you had fun watching don't
forget to hit that subscribe button to
keep up with all of our latest videos